deux cérémonies entaché également par
une centaine d'incidents dont certains
établissements scolaires dans ce
contexte les profs sont payés de
transmettre les valeurs de la république
ou alors ne quitter l'enseignement
petite piqûre de rappel de jean michel
blanc guerre ce matin alors transmettre
les valeurs de la république réalité ou
utopie c'est la question on vous pose
dès 21h
[Musique]
mais ça va en de parler donc du pouvoir
d'achat petit détour du côté de
l'assemblée nationale car les députés
ont commencé aujourd'hui examiné le
projet de loi censé notamment prolonger
le pass sanitaire jusqu'à l'été 2022 on
y retrouve notre reporter lucas léger
bonsoir lucas le texte sensible donc
soulève de nombreuses critiques au sein
de l'hémicycle le point de crispation la
possible extension donc de se passer ni
terre jusqu'en juillet 2022
absolument les députés ont commencé à
parler de ce texte en fin d'après midi
c'est un texte qui va être très scrutées
puisque il doit remplacer la loi qui va
prendre fin le 15 novembre date donc
c'est la loi qui encadre actuellement le
passo sanitaire parmi les mesures
emblématiques du texte la possibilité
pour le gouvernement de recourir au pass
sanitaires et à l'état d'urgence
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 il est aussi
prévu des sanctions plus importantes
pour les fraudeurs jusqu'à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et 75 mille euros
damende le gouvernement défend la mesure
comme une assurance en cas de reprise et
puis des beats notamment avec le variant
delta il ya des pays d'europe dans
lequel se variante circule beaucoup plus
fortement ils veulent donc éviter à un
nouveau confinement il assure que ces
mesures seront abandonnés dès que
possible dès que la situation le
permettra mais ça soulève quelques
scepticisme à l'assemblée nationale et
certains critiquent l'absence de
contrôle du parlement sur une longue
période je vous propose d'écouter ce que
nous en a dit fabien roussel députés
communistes que j + interrogé tout à
l'heure on a le droit de prendre le
métro mais on peut pas aller au café
peut aller acheter faire son tiercé dans
un café sans pass sanitaire mais pour
rentrer pour prendre pour aller au
comptoir il faut le présenter enfin il
ya plein d'incohérences et aujourd'hui
il ya un taux d'incidence tellement bas
dans le pays que nous pourrions sortir
de ce pass sanitaires et reprendre une
vie quasi normale et donc nous allons
nous voter contre ces nouvelles mesures
de restriction et et de mise en oeuvre a
pas sanitaires au delà de ce qui devrait
être c'est surtout pour le gouvernement
la possibilité de continuer à décider
tout seul avec le président de la
république enfermé dans son conseil de
défense et sans associer les
parlementaires la diversité des
parlementaires et de toutes les
populations que nous représentons de
tous les territoires d'outre-mer de
métropole de la campagne des grandes
villes cette diversité au parlement elle
est importante pour justement prendre
les bonnes décisions je regrette que le
gouvernement maintenant depuis le début
on est quasiment sous état d'urgence
constamment
dans la rue à l'extérieur du bâtiment il
y avait eu plusieurs manifestations
d'opposants aux passes sanitaires
notamment une manifestation de gilet
jaune en début d'après midi et à 17
heures une manifestation organisée par
le parti les patriotes de florian
philippot je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'il nous a dit
qu'ils croient encore une seconde tout
ce qui sort de la bouche de ce
gouvernement ce sont que des mensonges
qui sort de leur bouche haut depuis 18
mois au moins mentir le pass devait pas
exister puis pas être étendus puis pas
prolonger finalement est prolongée tout
ça c'est pour faire plaisir aux grands
labos c'est tout c'est pas ça vide aux
parents leur sens réveil nous voit ses
députés là ils arrêtent de trahir le
peuple ils votent par la baisse des
taxes sur l'essence l'électricité le gaz
il le e-vote pour une bonne éducation
une bonne sécurité bonnet un peu
d'écoles ou de bonne santé par exemple
de nouveaux véhicules flexity soit ils
sont complices de cette indignité parce
que c'est une indignité et je rappelle
que dans plus de 90% des pays du monde
mis à l'eau à plus de 90% des pays du
monde y'a pas de façade donc c'est une
anomalie insupportable inutile
inefficace et indigne se passe il faut
le dégager
si cette loi un peu de chance d'être
entravée devant l'assemblée nationale
cela pourrait être différent devant le
sénat le président de la chambre haute
gérard larcher a dit qu'il ne voulait
pas donner un blanc seing au
gouvernement jusqu'en juillet il veut un
contrôle du parlement entre-temps le
parlement qui va rentrer en vacances à
partir de février et jusqu aux élections
et à la prochaine législature et puis
vous a pu le voir il y aura toujours des
manifestants dans les rues pour
contester ces mesures ils ont prévu de
se mobiliser jusqu'à l'ouverture totale
du pays merci le cas légers à noter
injustement que le pass sanitaire ce
sera l'objet demain de notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français
le pouvoir d'achat donc est désormais le
premier sujet de préoccupation des
français résultats d'un sondage
opinionway les échos des ménages plombé
évidemment par notamment la hausse des
prix de l'énergie face à l'urgence le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent promet des mesures de protection
cette semaine en attendant les députés
viennent de voter le premier volet du
budget 2022 qui comprend le bouclier
tarifaire pour contenir la hausse des
prix du gaz et d'électricité l'exécutif
est il vraiment tout son possible pour
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français la réponse avec david khalifa
argent trop cher chanter le groupe
téléphone c'est un peu le constat amer
qu'on peut faire à la fin de ce
quinquennat qui dit présidentielle dit
forcément évident emmanuel macron comme
ses prédécesseurs nazis pas le mettre en
avant un bilan sur le papier plutôt bon
selon les calculs de le fc le pouvoir
d'achat 3 en moyenne de 1% par an et par
unité de consommation entre 2017 et 2022
ce qui correspond à un gain annuel moyen
de l'ordre de 334 euros par an ce qui
est plus que nicolas sarkozy ou françois
hollande mais encore loin de jacques
chirac comme on peut le voir sur ce
graphique pourtant 56% des français
jugent selon un sondage opinionway pour
les échos que leur pouvoir d'achat a
plutôt diminué pendant ce quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron un tiers pense qu'il
est resté plutôt stable et seulement 8 %
jugent qu'il a plutôt augmenté de quoi
s'interroger sur la manière de calculer
car le pouvoir d'achat dépend à la fois
de l'évolution des revenus et des prix
or beaucoup de facteurs extérieurs sur
lesquels le gouvernement n'a pas
forcément ait la main-mise influence
fortement ces deux éléments le site
alternatives économiques a fait ses
propres calculs on ne s'attachant pas
aux pourcentages mais aux euros
redistribuer sur cinq ans sur l'ensemble
des 24 milliards d'euros 5 milliards
iraient aux plus aisés soit 22% contre
1,5 milliard pour les plus modestes soit
6%
les gains des 10% les plus pauvres
s'élèverait donc à 346 euros sur cinq
ans et à 1178 euros pour les 10 % les
plus riches il y a effectivement
plusieurs façons de voir les choses en
pourcentage du niveau de vie ou en
répartition de l'ensemble en milliards
des mesures or on voit bien que lorsque
l'on privilégie la seconde ça raconte
une autre histoire avec un quinquennat
marqué par l'allègement de la fiscalité
du capital qui a naturellement
bénéficier davantage aux classes les
plus aisées alors qui croire en tout cas
l'opposition politique à s'approprier le
gouvernement prend les français pour des
abrutis en nous expliquant alors là
c'est les chiffres récents donc
le niveau de vie augmente et donc moi
j'aimerais bien savoir honnêtement
j'aimerais bien savoir on a perdu deux
ans de croissance les plans de
licenciements ont explosé la dares nous
dit plus de mille plans de licenciements
la vie est plus chère sur de nombreux
produits je pense aux produits aux
produits frais +2 4% le gaz
l'électricité plus de 12%
toutes les autres évaluations
précédentes qui ont mesuré un peu les
effets de la politique d' emmanuel
macron sur sur les français montrent que
par exemple les 5 % les plus pauvres y
perdent tandis que les plus riches se
voient leurs revenus exploser dans le
détail cette réaction n'est pas si est
démesuré car si on se penche sur les
chiffres de l'insee la pandémie n'a fait
qu'accentuer une précarité déjà bien
présentes avant 2019 par exemple le
nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa a atteint
2,1 millions en octobre 2020 soit 7 5 %
de plus que l'année précédente
le secours populaire de son côté alerte
sur le fait que de plus en plus de
français ne mangent pas à leur faim huit
millions de personnes ont bénéficié d'
aide alimentaire en 2020 soit une hausse
de 10% selon l'association en cause le
coût de l'alimentation
le ticket de caisse moyen a déjà grimpé
de 2 5% en 2010 9 de 1,9 pour cent l'an
dernier tiré par une flambée des
étiquettes des légumes fruits poissons
conséquence un français sur cinq
déclarent ne pas avoir les moyens de
manger trois repas par jour aujourd'hui
dans la rue la contestation populaire
voit bien le gaz calais qu'à augmenter
d'électricité car nos ventes et notre
pouvoir d'achat qui est de plus en plus
affaibli donc je pense que c'est une
bonne une bonne raison de ressortir en
fait et d'ailleurs on ressent pas on est
resté sauf que on a été plus discret il
ya tout qui augmente sauf nos salaires
donc peut-être qu'il faudrait que le
gouvernement
site de faire quelque chose l'embellie
des chiffres ne reflètent donc pas la
réalité des faits et à l'aube d'une
élection présidentielle c'est bien
souvent ce qui fait la différence dans
les urnes est plus que jamais au centre
un de cette problématique du pouvoir
d'achat à la hausse des prix du
carburants les prix à la pompe ont
encore augmenté de 2 centimes la semaine
dernière et justement en six mois de la
présidentielle les candidats déclarés ou
non ils vont chacun de leurs
propositions pour faire baisser la
facture à la pompe florilège de ces
mesures envisagées avec ses vestes un
tabac avec des prix du sans plomb et du
gazole atteignant respectivement jusqu'à
1 euro 77 et 1 euros 72 ce mardi les
automobilistes français attendent les
mesures du gouvernement mais aussi les
propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle et ces derniers n'ont pas
tardé à s'exprimer du côté du
gouvernement plusieurs scénarios sont à
l'étude le ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire plaide pour un chèque carburant
qui pourrait atteindre 400 euros pour
les ménages les plus modestes et 100
euros pour les ménages aux revenus
moyens il est d'ailleurs rejoint par le
candidat écologiste yannick jadot sur
cette proposition la ministre de la
transition écologique barbara pompili
propose elle une baisse de la marge des
distributeurs
une idée que certains ont déjà commencé
à appliquer en vendant leur carburant à
prix coûtant mais qu'en est il des
autres candidats à la présidentielle le
candidat de la france insoumise propose
le blocage pur et dur de la hausse des
prix un seuil en théorie infranchissable
et qui protégerait des consommateurs des
hausses potentielles une mesure déjà
adoptée par le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe lors de la crise des gilets
jaunes une fois n'est pas coutume la
candidate du rassemblement national
marine le pen et arnaud montebourg sont
d'accord sur une baisse de la tva sur
l'essence pour passer de 20% à 5,5 pour
cent valérie pécresse également
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
propose une prise en charge de
l'indemnité kilométrique des salariés
actuellement cette mesure offre une
déduction fiscale aux entreprises qui
recourent la candidate lr voudrait que
les employeurs prennent entièrement à
leur charge cette mesure
pour l'heure le gouvernement a annoncé
l'exploration de plusieurs pistes le
porte parole du gouvernement doit
annoncer d'ici la fin de la semaine
quelle aide sera retenue en attendant
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
et des carburants des gilets jaunes ont
annoncé de nouvelles manifestations dès
cette semaine
alors question comment améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat des français en pleine
flambée des prix de l'énergie on en
parle maintenant avec nos invités on
vous a aussi posé la question ce soir
sur le conte télégramme verte et
français leur de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir deux
porte-paroles représentants de deux
candidats à la présidentielle de 2000 22
sur ce plateau françois cocq porte
parole d'arnaud montebourg bonsoir
françois cocq merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés on skype un philippe ballard
porte parole du rassemblement national
bonsoir philippe ballard merci d'être
avec nous on le disait en introduction
assez ces annonces du gouvernement
attendue d'ici la fin de la semaine sur
les prix des carburants on a hâte parce
que effectivement les l'équation n'est
pas simple à résoudre en attendant les
candidats son move dans les brèches je
vous propose tout d'abord d'écouter
cette déclaration de marine le pen ce
matin la candidate du rassemblement
national
il faut baisser la tva sur le carburant
le fioul le gaz l'électricité de 20 à 5
5 % parce que ce sont des produits de
première nécessité les français pourront
immédiatement respirer et voir leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter
constante dans ses propositions marine
le pen qui avait déjà proposé la baisse
des sax philippe ballard ça y est la
question migratoire passe derrière le
pouvoir d'achat clairement vous êtes
haut niveau sur ces questions
rassemblement national n'ont pas toute
motion et un sondage qui est sorti
d'ailleurs qu'il passe le pouvoir
d'achat en tête des préoccupations des
françaises et des français il ya ensuite
la sécurité la santé et et l'immigration
donc le pouvoir d'achat touche parce que
là dans les exemples que vous montrez on
voit que c'est c'est pas péjoratif ce
que je vais dire le petit peuple cette
france ben 7 ce rural qui souffrent qui
est obligé de sa voiture qui roule au
diesel parce qu'on leur a dit pendant
des années rouler au diesel c'était très
bien et maintenant il se retrouve le bec
dans l'eau l'état est en train de
s'enrichir pendant que les français se
déplume donc c'est pas possible ce n'est
pas tolérable on va rappeler quand même
que le prix de l'essence et 60% de tat
et c'est pour ça que marine le pen
propose de baisser la tva de 20 à 5 5%
sur l'essence comme sur le gaz
l'électricité et les produits de
première nécessité parce qu'on parle
beaucoup à juste titre du carburant mais
il ya d'autres études qui nous montrent
que des français un tiers des français
commencent à réduire son show son
chauffage par peur de ne pas pouvoir
payer la facture donc emmanuel macron
président du pouvoir d'achat ça fait
juste rire un dernier chiffre avant
d'entamer le débat même si je pense
qu'il sera question des centres on a
même proposition donc mais dans le
projet de loi de finances il y a marqué
que le pouvoir d'achat sous ce
quinquennat progressé lui pour cent il
vous rappeliez de sondages d'opinionway
60% des français estiment tout
simplement la baisse effectivement
beaucoup de difficultés à faire un
diagnostic il faut bien dire françois
cocq assez rigoureux parce que chacun y
va de son étudié les chiffres de l'insee
d'un côté les chiffres voilà d'autres
sources peut-être qu'on voit aussi avec
le prisme de ses opinions politiques
tout d'abord pour rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire philippe à la
position d'arnaud montebourg sur ce
diagnostic de pouvoir d'achat il n'y
aurait pas cette flambée des prix de
l'énergie
aujourd'hui clairement les français ont
pu gagner mais où mon pouvoir d'achat
selon vous mais non seulement il y à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie et que le
gouvernement n'at-il pas agi plus tôt
quand même j'entends que le gouvernement
devrait agir d'ici la fin de la semaine
il apparaît agit en amont et encore
aujourd'hui il prend le temps c'est à
dire que les prix flambent et pendant ce
temps monsieur macro
france et mijoté
quelle célérité quelle célérité ces gens
sont absolument dans le coup et ils sont
en phase avec les préoccupations des
français non tout cela n'est tout cela
n'est pas sérieux et comme
que comme celles évoquées aujourd'hui il
ya des chiffres différents sur la table
d'un côté il ya le chiffre des instituts
économiques et de l'autre côté il ya la
propagande gouvernementale
et il ne faut pas se tromper et les
français ne s'y trompent pas parce que
leur quotidien va vers ce que nous
disent les différents les différents
instituts est pas ce que dit monsieur
macro donc la question est maintenant
comment on redonne des marges de
manoeuvre aux français qui sont
totalement étranglé par cette situation
sur la question du de l'essence
effectivement le prix de l'essence
aujourd'hui où le prix du le prix du
gazole ses 44 % du produit et la
distribution et puis le reste c'est des
taxes alors il ya des gens qui ont agi
j'entendais michel edouard leclerc dire
que lui ben finalement il vendait à prix
coûtant le gouvernement je le constate
est encore à la traîne là dessus mais
sur les 56 % de taxes il ya ce qu'on
appelle la tei cpe la taxe intérieure
sur la consommation des produits
énergétiques et puis il ya la tva il
faut savoir la tva allait sur l'essence
et elle est sûre la tei cpe c'est à dire
qu'elle taxe sur la taxe tout cela n'est
pas sérieux aujourd'hui sur un litre
d'essence il ya environ 27% de 25
centimes par don de taxes de tva si on
ramener la tva de 20 2 20% à 5 et demi
pour cent ça ferait gagner 20 centimes
par litre qu'on rendrai aux français et
finalement refait passer le prix de
l'essence à ce qu'il était au mois de
février tout ça est une mesure de bon
sens applicable immédiatement qui aurait
déjà dû être appliqué en même temps que
le blocage des prix et une fois encore
on est en train d'attendre monsieur
macron vous êtes d'accord donc sur ce
diagnostic la baisse des taxes philippe
ballard beaucoup vous des gens ont dit
cet argument d'inégalités parce que ça
se fabrique finalement tous les français
n'ont pas les français les plus
défavorisés qu'est ce qu'on vous leur
répondez
non mais effectivement si on baisse de
la tva de 20 5 5% tout le monde en
bénéficiera en quelque sorte y compris
la personne qui fait son plein dans un
gros 4 4 et tu vas prendre sa voiture
pour aller passer son week-end à
deauville en venant de paris m'en
fallait y aller on est dans l'urgence on
est dans l'urgence il faut que le
gouvernement l'entende monsieur macron
est très ans qui avec les formes et les
très dur avec les faibles et il le
montre encore une fois ce soir en
tergiversant alors on attend peut-être
la fin de la semaine un chèque alors à
chaque énergie c'est existe déjà mais il
faut avoir quand même quelques chiffres
en tête pour en bénéficier il faut
gagner
1500 euros par an c'est-à-dire faut
gagner en gros 800 euros par mois enfin
ce on se moque du monde donc tout ça
n'est pas sérieux et puis après parce
que là on est dans les mesures d'urgence
mais il ya des mesures quand même de
long terme on nous a vendu la
mondialisation aux qui s'est transformée
en un véritable cauchemar pour des
millions de françaises et de français
il y à une étude de la bce la banque
centrale européenne ça vient pas du
rassemblement national qui est sorti il
ya quelques jours et qui affirme que le
salaire médian ce qui est vrai en france
se servait remédier ancillaires la
moitié viennent plus et la moitié
gagnent moins ses 1800 euros par mois
vous entendez bien 1800 euros pour la
moitié des des salariés et l'explication
c'est que la france s'est
désindustrialisée
voilà on a ruiné les français emmanuel
macron n'est pas le seul responsable
il faut revoir complètement notre schéma
économie relocalisée on va enclencher un
cercle vertueux les entreprises
embaucheront elles investiront elles
pourront augmenter les salaires il faut
en finir avec cette phase de la
mondialisation heureuse et de ses
accords de libre échange qui ruine une
grande partie des françaises et des
français dont une petite partie qui vont
profiter
or justement à nant le pendant de votre
réaction philippe ballard les premiers
messages de nos téléspectateurs sur
telegrah verte et france sandrine fbi
hausse du smic et des salaires que les
riches partage au lieu d'aller planquer
leur argent dans les paradis fiscaux au
retour de miss f1 sur cette question de
l'augmentation des salaires d'une part
françois cocq et du fait que certains
profiteraient beaucoup plus que d'autres
votre réponse
bien sûr bien sûr le pan dont deux
aujourd'hui de ce qu'il faut faire et ce
qu'il faut mettre en place comme comme
mesure immédiate c'est de mettre en
place des mesures structurelles on voit
bien que dans la société il y as besoin
d'un rattrapage depuis déjà des années
les salariés
font tondre donc aujourd'hui il faut
qu'il y ait un rattrapage sur la
question des salaires c'est-à-dire 10%
d'augmentation immédiate du smic et on
ouvre un grand grenelle des salaires où
on augmente tous les salaires en dessous
de 2000 euros avec des discussions par
branche voilà ce qu'il faut faire voilà
comment un moment donné il faut redonner
un petit peu d'abord de dignité au
travail parce que les gens vivent par
leur travail et ils sont fiers de cela
il faut le leur rendre aussi avec un
salaire qui est qui qui sont un peu
digne et non pas comme il est
aujourd'hui à la baisse depuis des
années je les vois requis baisse puisque
vous aurez noté que la petite inflation
qui reprend est supérieur aux maigres
augmentations de salaires qui ont été
accordés aux français c'est un débat
philippe ballard vous avez l'air d'accès
mais voilà ce cette question
d'augmentation des jeux vous fait
peut-être dire ce que vous ne vouliez
pas dire mais je vais vous donner la
parole sur cette question évidemment de
l'augmentation des salaires et notamment
du smic on sait que beaucoup
d'économistes met en garde justement
contre cette augmentation
sur l'emploi votre avis au rassemblement
national nous augmenter également les
salaires comme cheikh normand beau
on est on est notre logique
notre slogan c'est rendons leur argent
aux fonds ses rangs de leur pays
également mais nous ne sommes pas pour
des augmentations de salaire de l'autre
j'entendais 10% enfin on côtoie
quasiment quotidiennement des déchets
d'entreprise des pme qui ont bu trois
quatre salariés c'est tout simplement
impossible ils sont mais juste la tête
hors de l'eau dont on a eu notre logis
le contraire il ya on en a bien quelques
jours souvenez-vous doit alors on pourra
parler des branches effectivement en
tension je pense de la restauration
hôtellerie ou là à part augmenter les
salaires et améliorer les conditions de
travail avec des accords de branche je
pense qu'on ne pourra pas mal à arrêter
voilà je pense à la restauration
l'hôtellerie c'est pas possible il ya de
bons services au service on n'a pas le
temps de rentrer chez soi on est payés
ou au smic on a des horaires à rallonge
donc là effectivement dans certains
secteurs il faudra qu'il y ait des
augmentations de salaires après pour
l'ensemble si on raisonne d'un point de
vue microéconomique
non micro et macro d'ailleurs économique
on peut pas augmenter les salaires comme
ça nous on a eu notre logis dont on veut
baisser la tva par exemple sur les
carburants sur le gaz l'électricité on
parle aussi d'une baisse une annulation
même de la redevance les dunes privé
d'une nationalisation par dans des
concessions automobiles tout ça ça rend
au fil de l'eau du pouvoir d'achat aux
français et par ailleurs on fera des
économies marie le pen a commencé à
présenter son programme avec une grande
partie sur l'immigration puisque les
allocations familiales seront réservées
aux français pour bénéficier de toutes
ces allocations solidarité comme le rsa
ou les allocations logement il faudra
avoir pour un étranger travaillé cinq
ans à taux plein quand vous le souhaitez
en france tous à ces 16 milliards
jusqu'à villiers a appuyé à la fraude
fiscale et sociale entre 15 et 45
milliards selon les rapports
parlementaires voyez il ya un peu de
grain à moudre et puis on parlait de ses
factures d'électricité ou on empile les
taxes sur les taxes sur les taxes sur
les taxes notamment les taxes pour les
énergies renouvelables les éoliennes
notamment ses 7 milliards au total là
aussi il ya des économies à faire dont
on n'oblige pas à augmenter les salaires
sauf dans certaines branches mais on
redonne de l'argent aux français par un
autre biais françois qu'aucun
rassemblement national on tente de nous
expliquer en tout cas que cet argent on
le récupère d'une certaine manière chez
vous comment on finance toutes ces
hausses de salaires justement d'abord on
finance en allant chercher l'argent chez
ceux qui en ont le plus profité tous les
ans 4,1 milliards d'euros disparaissent
parce que monsieur macron a fait un
cadeau à ses amis qui est la suppression
de lits est donc il est urgent de
rétablir lisf pour commencer
deuxièmement les entreprises aujourd'hui
en doublant les filles également bon il
faut commencer par établir lisf et
ensuite on a bien vu les fausses
réformes qui ont été tirés qui ont été
mises en place et qui de et qui devront
donc être derrière détricoter
deuxièmement les entreprises et 10 elles
mêmes qu'elles ont des marges sur les
salaires et qu'elles ressentent le
besoin aussi de rémunérer leurs salariés
pour faire vivre le collectif humain qui
est une entreprise il ne faut pas avoir
cette ville dogmatique qui est de dire à
ces pauvres aux entreprises aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont le couteau sous la gorge non
elles font vivre un collectif humain
elles savent que leurs salariés ont
besoin d'être rémunérés et ça ça veut
dire qu on augmente les salaires mais
aussi on met en place une fiscalité
juste parlem pour redistributif sur le
revenu et c'est là l'un des principaux
des accords que nous avons avec le
rassemblement national nous sommes pour
plus de justice fiscale c'est à dire que
chacun cotise aussi et et prenne sa part
dans l'effort national au regard de ce
qu'est son salaire et son et sont
revenus il ya des choses à mettre en
place de ce point de vue là il ya
beaucoup de verticalité qui a été mise
en place avec monsieur macro ceux qui
s'en tire le mieux ce sont ceux qui sont
en haut de l'échelle eh bien il faut
inverser aujourd'hui son rapport de
force je vous invite à découvrir en même
temps que moi c'est ce message augmenté
denis côté augmenter les salaires peut
se réformer ce système de solidarité
français en baissant les charges les
entreprises et planifier une fin du
système actuel car il n'est pas
soutenable démographiquement et
économiquement vous vous adhérez
philippe ballard à ceux à cette
proposition
oui il y avait beaucoup de choses
j'aurais juste revenir un instant sur ce
qui ce qui a été dit par le porte parole
de monsieur montebourg non la fiscalité
fassi vous me parlez des gaffes à
nourrir leur tordre le bras donc on
n'est pas tendre avec les gaffes à des
multinationales qui font l'optimisation
fiscale puisque malheureusement
l'optimisation c'est légal des
techniques financières qui sont
moralement condamnable donc voilà je
voulais juste rectifier ce point et
après dans la réflexion de l'autre
téléspectateurs il va il y avait un
mouiller avec démographie effectivement
il ya un hiver démographique
en europe et il faut qu'on s'en
préoccupe il y à une proposition qui a
été formulée par marine le pen y en a
même deux c'est d'une part concernant le
quotient canton à un deuxième enfant il
faut que ça soit une part entière et
puis on souhaite proposer pour les
couples une somme d'argent plus de 10 de
milliers d'euros pour s'installer dans
la vie qu'il rembourse avec un taux
d'intérêt extrêmement bas et qui
s'éteint à la naissance du troisième
enfant cette question de la démographie
elle est rarement soulevée mais elle est
fondamentale d'autant plus que l'autre
côté de la méditerranée là c'est pas un
hiver démographique mais c'est un coup
de chaud démographique françois quand
cette question de la démographie vont
trouver aussi qu'on n'en parle pas assez
excellent une des clés peut-être de
beaucoup de questions
c'est l'une des clés mais la clé
aujourd'hui c'est de permettre aux gens
qui sont en situation de vivre bien de
vivre dignement il faut aussi se
préoccuper de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
en place c'est ça qu'on ne fait pas
assez aujourd'hui à partir du moment où
on a remis le pays au travail où on a
reconstruit la france on a recréé une
dynamique vertueuse en ré
industrialisant en sortant de cette
mondialisation folle où on pas
reproduire à l'autre bout du monde des
produits nécessaires dont on a besoin
sur place et qui nous donnerait notre
tolosiens ça coûte trop cher en france
simplement des règles qui sont
totalement absurdes où on privilégie ce
qui a été fabriqué à dix mille
kilomètres plutôt que de le faire chez
nous monsieur macron a dit il ya 18 mois
qu'il fallait refaire une filière de
masques en france et aujourd'hui il
n'est pas capable de dire aux
collectivités territoriales de commander
leurs masques dans les entreprises
françaises il préfère leur dire d'aller
les commandes et en chine tout ça est
absurde ces gens
ces gens sont des livres mondialisateurs
y pense qu'il n'y a que la règle du
commerce qui fonctionne tout ça n'a pas
de sens aujourd'hui à un moment donné
nous sommes un roman paradigmatique où
il faut repenser l'état de la société la
manière dont on veut vivre c'est ça que
le coc ville nous a mis sous les yeux et
c'est ça que monsieur macron et ses
sbires sont incapables de lire et de
voir
le mot de la fin on y arrive déjà mais
malheureusement on n'a pas tiré
justement assez d'enseignement il ya eu
ce plan 2030 qui pourtant tente d'être
une réponse assez problématique c n'est
pas suffisant de la démagogie pour vous
à sept mois de la présidence où
je relisais l'allocution télévisée des
ménages matheron du 12 mars 2020 dans
laquelle il nous annonce et le
confinement il s'interrogeait je vous
invite d'ailleurs à la relire c'est très
intéressant de sueur et s'interroger est
ce qu'on n'est pas allé trop loin dans
la mondialisation oui évidemment et il
nous disait vous pouvez relire c'est
noir sur blanc il faut retrouver notre
souveraineté quel beau mot sanitaire
notre souveraineté alimentaire et on
al'impression c'était lié un an et demi
mais qu'on a oublié tout ça comment
oublier d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes
donc nous mais pour le localisme
produisons favorisons les circuits
courts j'entendais monsieur parler des
masques il faut savoir que 97% les
masques achetés en ce moment commande
publique ces masques sont achetées à
l'étranger
un an et demi après le début du
confinement on a tout oublié c'est
pathétique je pense que ce gouvernement
et ce président de la publique n'obtient
rien à faire à l'elysée merci philippe
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur ft france ce soir
dans le reste de l'actualité ces
tensions entre la pologne et bruxelles
sous le feu des critiques le premier
ministre polonais qui a tenté de se
défendre aujourd'hui devant le parlement
européen varsovie est renvoyé à ses
dérives antidémocratiques par la plupart
des groupes politiques en cause une
décision du tribunal constitutionnel
polonais contestant la primauté du droit
européen le premier ministre polonais
qui dénonce un chantage de bruxelles
eux qui décident de geler les 36
milliards de subventions et de prêts
promis à varsovie dans le cadre du plan
de relance européen posco vide et ce
n'est pas fini la présidente de la
commission a dit préparer d'autres
sanctions le récit de françois xavier
lambert
les salutations avant d explication
musclée devant les députés européens
la présidente de la commission a lancé
la première critique à l'égard du
premier ministre polonais pour ursula
von der leyen varsovie menace les
valeurs de l'ue eux
l'état de droit et la matière qui
cimente notre union c'est le fondement
de notre unité il est essentiel pour
protéger les valeurs sur lesquelles
notre union et fondé démocratie liberté
égalité et respect des droits humains
ses fruits
et c'est à cela que les 27 états membres
ont adhéré en tant que participant à
cette union en tant que pays souverain
et peuples libres
la présidente de la commission a
également évoqué des sanctions possibles
contre la pologne notamment la
suspension la réduction de fonds versés
à un pays ne respectant pas les
principes de l'état de droit ce discours
menaçant a provoqué la colère du premier
ministre polonais alors que son pays
attend toujours près de 36 milliards de
subventions européennes à la tête du
pays qui reçoit le plus d'argent de
l'uae matthaus muravyev qui dénonce un
chantage de bruxelles
il n'est pas acceptable d'imposer aux
autres ses décisions sans fondement
juridique il est d'autant pas acceptable
d'utiliser à cette fin le chantage
financier de parler de sanctions ont
utilisé un langage qui va encore plus
loin en l'encontre de certains pays
membres
je rejette ce langage des menaces ou de
la coercition je refuse que les
politiciens en face du chantage et
menace la pologne
cette passe d'armes illustre à nouveau
les tensions persistantes entre l'union
européenne et la pologne un conflit lié
à plusieurs réformes judiciaires
controversée mise en oeuvre par le parti
populiste de droite au pouvoir en
pologne mais c'est surtout une récente
décision du tribunal constitutionnel
polonais qui a dégradé les relations
avec bruxelles selon la juridiction
suprême polonaise certains articles des
traités de l'ue eux seraient
incompatibles avec la constitution du
pays une décision incompréhensible et
infondées pour les dirigeants européens
et de nombreux états membres redoutant
une sortie de lieux des dizaines de
milliers de polonais sont descendus dans
la rue pour scander leur attachement au
projet européen pour tenter d'apaiser
ses dissensions la chancelière allemande
sortante a dit préférer un dialogue avec
varsovie plutôt qu'un durcissement des
sanctions
comment organiser l'envoi d'une aide
humanitaire en afghanistan c'est toute
la question sont des discussions
internationales qui s'ouvre demain à
moscou des représentants russes chinois
et pakistanais participeront tout comme
une délégation des talibans plus de
pression avec notre correspondant
antoine claireaux enrichi
l'épineux dossier afghan était au coeur
de discussions ce mardi à moscou entre
des représentants de la russie de la
chine et du pakistan la question
centrale étant l'attitude à adopter face
au nouveau pouvoir en place à kaboul
pour la diplomatie russe la
reconnaissance officielle des talibans
n'est pas encore d'actualité des
contacts existent mais moscou espère
voir des progrès en particulier dans la
composition d'un gouvernement qui soit
plus inclusif plus représentatif de la
société afghane après avoir tenté de
dégager une position commune sur
l'afghanistan les représentants russes
chinois et pakistanais mais aussi ceux
de plusieurs pays d'asie centrale vont
donc rencontrer les talibans ce mercredi
pour des négociations directes à noter
cependant l'absence de représentants
américains qui s'étaient pourtant juin
lors des précédentes réunions au format
de la troïka est large
les etats unis sont donc les grands
absents des pourparlers sur
l'afghanistan on retrouve thomas bonnet
en direct de washington
bonsoir thomas est pourquoi moi je suis
pas mal finalement décidé de ne pas
participer c est des discussions à
moscou
et bien c'est assez difficile de vous
répondre puisque on a finalement eu que
des explications très laconique de la
part des autorités américaines
évidemment les états unis étaient censés
participer à ces discussions à moscou
mais selon le porte parole du
département d'état américain nate price
eh bien ce sont des raisons logistiques
qui ont empêché les états unis d'être
présent à ces discussions écoutez ses
explications
nous participerons pas aux pourparlers
de moscou la troïka est tendue a été un
forum efficace et constructif
nous avons hâte de participer à ce forum
à l'avenir mais nous ne sommes pas en
mesure d'y participer cette semaine
des explications assez peu convaincante
pour les journalistes qui étaient
présents à cette conférence de presse
qui ont relancé à plusieurs reprises ne
trahisse pour essayer d'obtenir les
véritables raisons de l'absence
américaine mais sans succès le porte
parole du département d'état américain
elle n'a pas voulu aller plus loin que
juste d'invoquer ces raisons logistiques
lydie contre le gouvernement avoue
et thomas dans le même temps les états
unis qui doivent faire face à la
démission de l'émissaire américain pour
l'afghanistan
oui le départ a été rendue officielle ce
lundi par le secrétaire d'état américain
anthony blinken zalmaï khalilzad a donc
quitté ses fonctions il occupait depuis
trois ans le poste d'émissaire américain
chargé de l'afghanistan est dans la
lettre de démission qu'il a donc adressé
à anthony blinken il fait un constat
d'échec écoutez le
l'accord politique entre le gouvernement
afghan et les talibans ne s'est pas
déroulé comme prévu les raisons pour
cela sont trop complexes et je
partagerai mes pensées dans les
prochains jours et semaines
alors il faut rappeler que zalmaï
khalilzad avait été nommé sous la
présidence de donald trump on sait aussi
qu'il a des liens avec les
néoconservateurs avec les fameux faucons
de l'époque de george w bush c'est
notamment lui qui avait mené beaucoup de
discussions avec les différentes parties
en afghanistan depuis 2018 il est
notamment celui qui était de l'impulsion
de l'accord qui a été trouvé qui a été
signé en 2020 entre les talibans et les
américains pour le retrait à des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan qui s'est
déroulée cet été et on assistait depuis
plusieurs mois à une façon une sorte de
ping pong puisqu'il se rejettent l
rejeter la faute entre l'administration
de la maison blanche qui estimaient
qu'ils avaient un peu les mains liées
par cet accord avec les talibans et donc
l'allemagne khalilzad qui explique que
le plan de route n'a pas été suivi à la
lettre son départ était finalement un
secret de polichinelle puisqu'il devait
déjà quitté son poste dès le mois de mai
mais l'administration de la maison
blanche lui avait demandé de rester
quelques mois supplémentaires et
d'ailleurs il y avait un signe qui ne
trompe pas puisqu'il n'a pas participé
aux discussions qui sont déroulés il ya
quelques jours à doha au qatar entre les
représentants américains et les
représentants des talibans celui qui
était à sa place c'est bien c'était son
ancien adjoint et c'est désormais lui
qui va occuper ce poste d'émissaire
américain en charge de l'afghanistan
merci à touba bonnet en direct de
washington et pour aller plus loin nous
sommes avec des videurs rigoulet roze
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique bonsoir david rigoulet roze
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france les états unis donc les grands
absents on vient d'en parler de ces
pourparlers washington qui évoque des
raisons logistiques son autre
justification sans doute évidemment que
ce n'est pas là la cause principale
non c'est un prétexte effectivement
d'ailleurs assez peu convaincante comme
vous l'avez fait remarquer c'est à dire
que la situation
s'y prêtait pas vraiment les américains
mais par louis se retrouver avec une
délégation à moscou en dépit
l'invitation formelle qui avaient été
faites à washington
parce que bayard ya quand même il faut
digérer le retrait qui a été pour le
moins chaotique en plus il ya que vous
l'avez évoqué également y aller
l'annoncé de la démission de zamal
khalilzad qui était celui qui avait
négocié l'accord de retrait justement et
qui a reconnu en grande partie l'échec
puisque ce qui avait été attendu les
attendus de cet accord n'ont pas été
pour le moins
couronnés de succès en tout cas en terme
de d'inclusivité gouvernementales et de
et de d'engagement par rapport aux
risques terroristes donc d'une certaine
manière les america's mettez ce préféré
rester hors jeu entre guillemets par
rapport à ce qu'il fait figure de
formats moscovite sur l'afghanistan
depuis plusieurs années et qui regroupe
les pays régionaux il ya une
régionalisation réalité de la structure
moscovite qui laisse un peu les
américains de côté alors coptes ont
maintenant justement attendre de cette
rencontre
on sait que ce sont les questions
sécuritaires notamment humanitaires qui
vont être abordés oui alors en affichage
il ya la dimension humanitaire puisque
la russie s'est proposé pour pour
assurer effectivement un
approvisionnement humanitaire d'urgence
mais sur le fond c'est la préoccupation
centrale c'est la question sécuritaire
d'ailleurs les dernières déclarations du
président poutine sur le risque
constitué par l'état vis à vis du
khorassan par rapport justement au aux
engagements talibans c'est montre bien
que c'est la préoccupation principale de
ce format qui rudy les pays régionaux en
l'occurrence la chine qui est très
préoccupé également évidemment les pays
d'aix
union soviétique d'asie centrale pour
lesquelles moscou à une attention toute
particulière l'inde le pakistan donc on
voit bien que ce sont tous les pays qui
sont
de l'afghanistan il n'est pas question
qu'un d'histoire des outils et si le
problème pour situation actuelle on sait
qu'il y avait déjà eu un sommet d'autres
sommets à organiser notamment en mars
dernier avec toujours cette inquiétude
quant aux hauts risques terroristes
est-ce qu'il est réel david rigoulet
roze justement pour la russie y est et
ses voisins d'asie
ah oui les réelles d'ailleurs
les derniers attentats le prouve un
effectivement il ya une recrudescence
d'attentats revendiqués par l'état
islamique du khorassan qui la branche
locale de l'état islamique
contre plusieurs mosquées avec des
dizaines de morts donc ça pose le
problème de la crédibilité sécuritaire
justement du gouvernement taliban et
c'est ce qui est pour eux un problème
majeur parce que il avait fondé la
légitimité de justement de deux de leurs
installations grande partie sur cette
crédibilité sécuritaire et sur des
engagements qu'ils auraient pris non
seulement vis-à-vis des américains mais
également vis-à-vis des russes lors le
passage à moscou à plusieurs reprises
2-2 d'éradiquer effectivement le danger
terroriste et puis de clarifier leurs
relations avec des groupes évidemment
historiquement al qaïda et puis des bas
des groupes périphériques qui ont été
liés à un moment ou un autre justement à
la mouvance talibane ce qui préoccupe
les chinois notamment le tous ceux qui
sont dans la mouvance
djihadiste ouïghours notamment mais pas
seulement donc c'est toute la fragilité
de l'asie centrale qui posait la
question sécuritaire dont pour les
russes et les pays d'asie centrale la
question du droit des respect humain
toujours un souci premier pour les
occidentaux est-ce que cela reste
finalement
crédible comme comme ceux ci à résoudre
aujourd'hui ont finalement l'urgence
dicte d'autres sujets
variés dichotomie assez nette entre
jaillir la posture des occidentaux de
manière assez large et puis les pays
régionaux qui sont concernés au premier
chef
pour ce qui est des occidentaux il ya
effectivement des exigences en matière
de droits humains notamment par rapport
aux femmes au fil accès à l'éducation en
particulier et donc à une forme de
conditionnalité
notamment par rapport à une
reconnaissance éventuelle du
gouvernement taliban qui a été posée
c'est moins le cas du côté des pays
justement du format moscovite parce
qu'ils sont leurs priorités premières
c'est évidemment de souhaiter un
gouvernement inclusif mai mais surtout
par rapport à des enjeux sécuritaires
qui sont qui joue que ce leurs
frontières donc la position est pas tout
à fait la même même si évidemment la
question de la reconnaissance ne pourra
pas se faire sans qu'il y ait un
consensus international minimale merci
beaucoup david rigoulet roze d'avoir été
avec nous et nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage ce soir
tenu des pourparlers sur l'afghanistan à
moscou dès ce mercredi donc et au su de
la russie un autre rendez-vous continue
le club international de discussion
valdaï à sotchi qui réunit chercheurs
personnalités politiques russes et
experts internationaux au programme de
ce forum aujourd'hui une question l'otan
at-elle enterré l'idée de consultations
avec la russie on retrouve en direct de
la station balnéaire notre
correspondante maëlys d'estrées bonsoir
maylis sergueï lavrov qui a donc évoqué
les relations entre la russie et l'otan
bonsoir stéphanie effectivement le chef
de la diplomatie russe était présent
lors de cette deuxième journée du club
de discussion valdaï où il a répondu aux
questions des journalistes sur la
suspension annoncée hier par la russie
de sa mission auprès de l'otan et de
celle de l'alliance à moscou une
décision qui je le rappelle a été prise
en réaction à celle révélée au début du
mois d'octobre par l'organisation
militaire de réduire encore davantage
les effectifs de la représentation
permanente russe à partir du 1er
novembre d'après sergueï lavrov s'est
elle autant de faire le premier pas pour
normaliser ses relations avec la russie
car cette dernière n'est pas à l'origine
de la décla de la dégradation actuelle
de ces relations écoutez
on part de cette prémisse de parce que
nous n'avons jamais commencé la
dégradation de nos relations ni avec le
temps et avec l'union européenne et avec
toute autre partie occidentale ou de
tout autre pays du monde
pour le ministre des affaires étrangères
l'alliance a enterré l'idée de
consultation avec moscou dans les
situations de crise et les échanges
d'information n'existe plus depuis
longtemps entre l'otan et la russie
écouter lorsque le ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'allemagne au déclare que
par ce pas la russie fait preuve qu elle
n est pas prête pour les négociations
moi je viens de rappeler
nos pas entrepris pour lancer des
négociations qui ont été ignorées par le
temps alors c'est tabulation donné par à
leurs représentants occidentaux on y
trouve la compréhension de la faiblesse
de la position et leur volonté de faire
porter le chapeau percutant d'autres à
ce qui est né reflètent que le manque de
la culture diplomatique et après ses
déclarations fort du chef de la
diplomatie russe il semblerait que la
balle soit désormais dans le camp de
l'alliance atlantique
merci merci maëlys d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france
le liban est il à l'aube d'une ère très
sombre un cinq jours après les combats
de rue à beyrouth qui ont fait sept
morts le leader des forces libanaises
serait en tout cas une guerre civile en
face le chef du hezbollah pro-iranien
met en garde le parti chrétien contre
une escalade des violences et précision
de notre correspondant au marsala
beyrouth
les accusations émises hier par hassan
nasrallah du hezbollah contre les forces
libanaises de sécurité suite aux
évènements tragiques dans le quartier de
taille ou non ne sont pas nouvelles le
hezbollah et le mouvement amal tout
comme leurs alliés accusent directement
les forces libanaises d'être responsable
de ce qui s'est passé dans le quartier
de taille on est leader des parcs
le leader du parti forces libanaises
samir geagea a déclaré que ces
événements pourraient pousser le pays à
la guerre civile dans son discours
d'hier hassan nasrallah en a parlé de
manière détaillée
il a également rappelé qu'il disposait
de 100 mille combattants armés certains
l'ont interprété comme une menace même
si dans son intervention hassan
nasrallah a précisé qu'il ne menaçait
personne il a expliqué que ses
combattants ne ferait que veiller sur la
paix civile au liban
la réaction des dirigeants libanais de
premier ordre n'a pas encore eu lieu ne
peut qu'évoquer maintenant les réactions
de certains analystes politiques qui
expriment les points de vue de telle ou
telle forme politique aucune déclaration
officielle n'a encore été faite jusque
là au niveau des dirigeants des blocs
parlementaires ou des chefs des partis
politiques
dans l'ensemble il faudra attendre un
certain temps avant la publication des
résultats des enquêtes après cela on
pourrait s'attendre à une réaction plus
compréhensible
selon certaines informations les
investigations de prompt selon certaines
informations les investigations ne
prendront pas beaucoup de temps et les
résultats de l'enquêté seront annoncées
prochainement ailleurs la main
et on va plus loin avec notre grand
reporter arte france régis le sommier
bonsoir ray rice
comment tout simplement résoudre cette
crise en limant qui semble s'accélérer
de jour en jour en ce moment la crise et
les profondes depuis deux ans à la
descente aux enfers du liban il faut
imaginer un pays où tous les voyants
sont au rouge
l'économie la monnaie les tensions
communautaires qui sont extrêmement on
sait que c'est un pays qui est
bâti sur le communautarisme et sur le
confessionnalisme faut le rappeler c'est
un pays qui ressemble pas par exemple à
la syrie qui a connu énormément de
problèmes mais qui n'a pas cette
structure est aujourd'hui cette
structure héritée de la guerre civile
des années 80 eh bien elle pose problème
mais elle pose problème parce qu'elle
est remise en cause par un certain
nombre de personnes de ses propres
communautés mais il ya une énorme
difficulté à dépasser on l'a vu quand à
la faveur de cette malheureuse explosion
du centre ville de beyrouth les français
ont essayé de devenir lalala emmanuel
macron s'est rendu au liban a essayé de
jouer finalement d'une sorte de
bienveillance que la france toujours
comment dire dispatch sur le liban est
de 7,2 cette image ça n'a pas fonctionné
on est revenu finalement on vieilles
habitudes de communautarisme est
aujourd'hui justement la faveur de l'
enquête sur cette explosion du centre de
beyrouth contestation notamment par le
hezbollah de la deûle enquête du juge
voilà une certaine façon provoqué les
manifestations les manifestations il y à
une confrontation une vieille
confrontation finalement une
confrontation entre les chiites et une
milice comment les forces libanaises qui
font rappeler n'est quand même pas une
milice de personnes qui sont se sont pas
du tout délai des commandes et des
décommandé personnes il y a un passé
derrière il ya un passé derrière le
hezbollah il ya un passé derrière toutes
ces communautés est aujourd'hui
effectivement les tensions est ce qu'on
l'a revu dans le quartier de taille
sonné jeudi dernier est quand même
regrettable parce qu'on n'avait pas vu
ça depuis la guerre civile jusqu'à
présent les libanais avait hésité d'une
certaine façon même s'ils ont subi deux
d'être contaminé par le jeu du
sectarisme en syrie il y a eu des
combats il ya eu des des tensions
énormes pendant ces deux trois dernières
années mais les libanais avaient
toujours et ont toujours à mon sens se
souvenir de cette guerre civile
épouvantable malheureusement ce qu'on a
revu à taille humaine et c'est quasiment
sur la ligne d anciens affrontements les
les camps les partisans des deux côtés
se tirer dessus parfois ouverts p j'ai
donc cédé scène j'avais qui ont marqué
l'esprit les esprits est ce que régis
aérien risque le liban rebascule dans
cette guerre civile aujourd'hui alors il
ya effectivement un risque parce que la
différence entre les 10 dernières années
quand il y avait le voisin syrien qui
descendait en enfer les libanais eux
avait d'une certaine façon conserver
même s'il y avait des difficultés une
une santé économique qui s'est
progressivement qui a progressivement
décliné
aujourd'hui la crise financière est
énorme la communauté internationale
n'est pas venu au chevet du liban ça
c'est une donne considérable même si joe
biden récemment accepté que il y ait des
approvisionnements notamment en
hydrocarbures égyptien et en électricité
jordanienne qui soit cheminée via la
syrie à des discussions pour que c'est
pour mettre en place ces structures pour
pouvoir vraiment épauler liban avance
ans personne n'a intérêt à ce que un
nouveau pays du moyen-orient
bascule dans la violence et bascule dans
la guerre civile le fait est que on a vu
aujourd'hui le discours d'hassan
nasrallah très clair avouant pour la
première fois que le hezbollah avait
cent mille combattants il n'y a pas eu
de réactions mais on est dans cette
confrontation n'est dans cette montée
des armes consent il ya une odeur de
poudre clairement qu ici ce qui se
répand et ce ne sont pas les divers
escarmouches qu'on a pu voir entre des
divers groupes qui existent toujours au
liban est un pays où des armes ne sont
jamais loin mais le évidemment
souhaitons que le liban n'en arrive pas
là qu'il arrive à retrouver une
cohérence et peut-être une aide de cette
communauté internationale parce que de
diminuer sa tête justement
financièrement comme elle
l'a fait à fonds perdus et c'était un
des principaux arguments comment preuve
justement avancée par le président
macron de dire nous n'allons pas venir
ou de jean yves le drian également nous
n'allons pas venir éternellement
investir dans dans ce pays si les choses
ne sont pas réglées le gouvernement le
le liban s'est trouvé un gouvernement il
s'est trouvé un nouveau premier ministre
mais il n'est pas allé les vielles
habitudes sont là elles sont claires le
problème c'est que au niveau du jeu
américain au liban il ya quand même des
choses qui sont pas tout à fait claires
notamment
évidemment ce qui ce que laisse penser
une partie des médias américains c'est
que c'est lire en entier derrière celle
irons évidemment qu'il ya derrière le
hezbollah on le sait mais le hezbollah
n'est pas que le problème du liban
heures résumé ça à une agression à l
iranienne comme on le voit parfois c'est
une annonce en ce cd problème libanais
la taxe sur le quartier de de taille ou
n'est elle a été en grande partie de la
faute des forces libanaises de samir
geagea donc on est voilà on est dans
l'affrontement sectaire et il n'y a pas
un camp et je précise que ses forces
sont soutenus par l'arabie saoudite donc
là encore une fois on retrouve
les vieux les vieux démons libanais avec
ses interventions de parrains de ces
divers groupes mais d'accuser simplement
l'iran et de dire 'voilà et le problème
qu'on a dans dans depuis depuis depuis
très longtemps on se rend compte sur la
nature de l'intervention ou la nature de
de la politique américaine au
moyen-orient c'est de dire quand on
n'est pas d'accord quand on le pays ne
va pas dans le sens dans lequel on va on
veut qu il aille eh bien on prend on
pratique des sanctions on pratique par
le biais de l'extraterritorialité de la
loi américaine est bien une imposition
une interdiction de la plupart des
grandes compagnies d'investir dans le
pays donc finalement qui paye les pots
cassés à la fin c'est le peuple c'est
déjà le cas en syrie c'est le cas en
iran est-ce que ça va être encore à
nouveau le cas en liban au liban est ce
qu'on va affamer les gens je rappelle
qu'à une époque compte y avait un
problème avec un pays qui avait qui
avait feint un pays où qui connaissait
des famines on intervenait pour donner
de la nourriture aujourd'hui la
communauté internationale en particulier
l'occident intervient pour affamer des
populations donc la question elle est là
est-ce qu'on veut encore est-ce qu'on
veut pousser sur le bouton plus loin
évidemment les iraniens ne sont pas
totalement innocent dans cette histoire
il ya aussi une réforme est d'aider
comment des leviers à appuyer de ce côté
là c'est une c'est un grave problème
aujourd'hui à prendre en cause d'eux
parlant de l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
sinon le liban va revenir à ce qu'il a
connu c'est à dire les démons de la
guerre civile les années 80 l'horreur
merci beaucoup régis le sommier d'avoir
été avec nous on reste avec nous dans
quelques instants après une courte pause
alors on rend des hommages à la semaine
dernière au professeur assassiné samuel
bâti un couple d'enseignants ont reçu
des menaces de mort à marseille dans ce
contexte les profs sont priés de
transmettre les valeurs de la république
ou alors quitté l'enseignement petite
piqûre de rappel de jean michel blanquer
aujourd'hui alors transmettre les
valeurs de la république réalité ou
utopie aujourd'hui en france c'est la
question qu'on vous pose
[Musique]
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
trop de sécurité mettre en danger nos
libertés
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur la bbc une surréaliste
et hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qu'ils aient accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
soupçon diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et à l'aide
d'un système très curatif c'est
essentiel d'avoir l'information pour pas
subir
[Musique]
21h merci de rejoindre pour cette
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
le projet de loi de vigilance sanitaire
débattu par les députés depuis y ait ce
mardi le texte du gouvernement prévoit
la possibilité de pouvoir recourir au
pacini terre et aux mesures d'urgence
jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain en réaction
les gilet jaune se sont donné rendez
vous devant l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui pour dénoncer ce projet de
loi chez les politiques la colère monte
aussi certains opposants dénoncent une
façon d'enjamber la présidentielle
alors qu'on rendait hommage à semaine
dernière au professeur assassiné samuel
bâti un couple d'enseignants a reçu des
menaces de mort à marseille une
cérémonie entachée par une centaine
d'incidents dans plusieurs
établissements scolaires dans ce
contexte des profs sont priés de
transmettre les valeurs de la république
ou alors de quitter l'enseignement
petite piqûre de rappel de jean michel
blanquer aujourd'hui alors transmettre
les valeurs de la république réalité ou
utopie c'est la question que l'on nous a
posé aujourd'hui
il devait être allégé dans un mois mais
le pain sanitaire pourrait finalement
être prolongée jusqu'à cet été fin
juillet même prolongation prévue par
l'article 2 du projet de loi vigilance
sanitaire examiner cet après midi par
les députés plus de 380 amendements ont
été déposés pour la première lecture de
ce texte une majorité
concernés par cette promotion est ce
team que c'est une prolongation
controversée opposés à cette mesure les
gilet jaune ont manifesté aujourd'hui
devant l'assemblée nationale
vous avez à peu près six ou sept
millions de citoyens de plus de 18 ans
qui aujourd'hui ne pas pu lui même pas
prendre le train et tout ce qui concerne
le le quotidien tous ces privations je
pense qu'avant notre faut stopper ça il
peut pas y avoir le citoyen et le sous
citoyens j'ai pas peur des mots c'est
une dictature et c'est une ségrégation
sanitaires et j'aimerais qu'on soit pas
une poignée de personne dort jamais
conçoit des milliers qu'on envahissent
la place qu'on en baisse paris qu'on
envahissent les ronds points et qu'on
obtienne gain de cause on la cinquième
république agonise que deviendra tel
dans les semaines et les mois prochains
il fut très inquiet pour eux les lois
france même pas sanitaires et des gens
place de mai plus de trois mois en
france qu est moi-même un prolongement
est envisagée par le gouvernement pour
encore au moins neuf mois l'exécutif qui
n'exclut pas non plus de rendre la
troisième dose obligatoire on en parle
avec notre éditorialiste alexis poulain
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis c'est votre sujet préféré
prolongation est celui qui vous donne le
sourire prolongation lui passe vous êtes
heureux jusqu'au 2022 les députés en
tout cas sont en débat aujourd'hui à pas
mal d'amendements on voit c'est un texte
controversé une possibilité d' abandon
après le 15 novembre et croyant encore
je suis crois pas malheureusement et je
pense que beaucoup de français n'y croit
pas on voit bien que de toute façon la
majorité la république en manchette aux
ordres du gouvernement donc six et
menait le maquereau en conseil de
défense sanitaire a décidé que le pass à
lithaire devait aller jusqu'au 22
juillet où vous en juillet 2022 par la
fin juillet le 22 juillet je sais pas
pourquoi il dit loin de vieira jusqu'en
juillet voire même au-delà et c'est bien
tout le problème parce que il y avait
une motion de rejet on aurait pu arrêter
les discours et dire on ne perd pas de
temps à discuter d'une idée aussi
stupide et là on va avoir un débat de
carton à l'assemblée nationale avec des
députés qui vont aller dans le sens du
gouvernement pour la majorité mais même
pour certains aussi qu'ils vont se
rallier en disant il faut une précaution
et donc on va enjamber l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'il faudra avoir
recours à se passe si jamais il faut
être vigilant comme le dit gabriela tête
si jamais une cinquième vague pouvait
arriver puis une sixième bague fini
septième vague enfin on voit bien qu'il
ya quelque chose de très grave parce que
finalement c'était à d'urgence permanent
18 mois et bien il va durer encore très
longtemps si les députés votent pour
cette prolongation et c'est une mise
entre parenthèses de la démocratie c'est
inacceptable en réalité est pourtant on
vote le conseil constitutionnel le
conseil d'état valide également et ça
continue et c'est un état de vigilance
qui s'installe où finalement on n'est
plus vraiment dans un état de liberté
comme on a connu on est en état de
liberté en sursis de manière permanente
ou en liberté probatoire avec ce fameux
parce qu'il va falloir montrer encore
longtemps malheureusement je le crains
alors le ras-le-bol des élus commencent
à se faire sentir comme en témoigne
cette tribune des mers paru aujourd'hui
dans figaro vox c'est un début de fronde
je crois que c'est un début de fronde et
puis surtout un début de réalité les
élus de terrain savent ce que ce qu'est
le pass sanitaire dans cette tribune des
maires de savoie il explique que la
journée les enfants à l'école vont jouer
au basket dans un gymnase et le soir ces
mêmes enfants s'ils sont à l'association
sportive doivent non impasse sanitaire
pour jouer dans le même gymnase donc il
voit très bien que ça n'a aucun sens
comme on l'a vu quand on a dit que le
planétaire n'a pas lieu d'être dans les
transports en commun ni certains rer
mais par contre dans les tgv oui comme
on l'a vu sur la façon dont il fallait
le montrer d'une façon enfin bref ce
pass sanitaire n'a rien de salutaire et
les élus de terrain s'en rendent compte
et dans cette tribune ils disent surtout
que c'est un noyau de discorde des
familles sont en train de se fâcher des
gens qui jusqu'à présent vivaient
ensemble sont en train de se séparer
pour rien puisque s'il passe sanitaire
fonctionner eh bien on devrait l'arrêter
le taux d'incidence est bas dans tous
les départements la vaccination est au
plus haut en europe pour la france donc
il n'y a pas de raison de continuer se
passe à nous taire tous les pays qui ont
mis en place le pass sanitaire l'ont
arrêté dès que l'épidémie était sous
contrôle quitte à le remettre alors on
nous parle de la lettonie on nous fait
peur gabriella talent nous parle bien
sûr de cinquième vague la réalité c'est
qu'on ne doit pas s'habituer à ce passe
sanitaires et qu'il n'a pas à durée de
manière pérenne c'est proprement
scandaleux cette société de vigilance ne
doit pas s'installer dans nos vies et du
point de vue des françaises se passe est
encore acceptable de l'ajustement du nu
15 novembre un refus de 2,2 masse d'un
système qui tend à justement comme vous
dites à devenir pérenne je crois que
beaucoup de français qui ont accepté
l'idée du parce qu'ils ont même accepté
la vaccination à deux doses mais pour
qui la troisième dose va être un peu la
dose de trop et s'ils se passe doit
rester pour les forcer à la troisième
dose alors ça risque vraiment vraiment
là de compliquer les choses notamment
chez les plus jeunes on comprend pour
les personnes à risque les plus âgés qui
ont été les premiers vaccinés et eux
donc aurait besoin d'un booster mais
pour ceux qui sortent de l'été se sont
fait vacciner à qui on va demander une
troisième dose en janvier peut-être là
ça va être un peu plus compliqué parce
que pourquoi on va dire d'ailleurs le ms
n'a pas validé forcément la troisième
d'autres et puis la question de la
dangerosité de cette troisième dose
moderna maintenant et des conseillers
pour la troisième dose s'était pas que
ya quelques semaines on nous disait ya
aucun danger alesi cours isi or les pays
du nord ont émis des alertes et puis la
france a suivi avec la haute autorité de
santé avec quelques semaines de retard
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on ne
sait toujours pas il ya beaucoup de
réponses qu'on attend et pourtant le
gouvernement veut continuer dans cette
logique du tous contre tous parce que
divisés ça permet de régner ça permet
d'occuper le terrain et aussi ça permet
bien sûr de mettre la présidentielle
finalement sous une épée de damoclès cdu
covit celle du pass sanitaires même si
on nous garantit que le pass and i ter
ne sera jamais utilisée pour aller voter
regardez emmanuel macron nous promettait
il ya quelques mois de cela que jamais
le pass sanitaire ne serait demandée
pour les activités du quotidien aucune
confiance dans la parole du gouvernement
merci alexis paulin d'avoir été avec
nous et les mesures sanitation déclenché
une crise sociale en guyana le préfet a
ordonné hier la fermeture des stations
service dont tout ce territoire
d'outre-mer une partie de l' usine de
stockage est bloqué par des manifestants
les autorités craignent une pénurie de
carburant les détails avec solène goda
des files d'attentes interminables
ce lundi matin les stations service
étaient prises d'assaut en guyane en
cause leur fermeture imminente sur
décision du préfet suite au blocage du
dépôt de la sarraz par la caravane de la
liberté ut g le préfet a décidé par
arrêté préfectoral de fermer les
stations service en raison de la pénurie
potentielle de carburant le but éviter
la panne sèche depuis lundi matin
plusieurs dépôts de carburants sont
bloqués par des manifestants
ils réclament une table ronde avec les
autorités pour mettre fin aux mesures de
restrictions sanitaires et obtenir plus
de moyens pour le système de santé dans
la région la préfecture le préfet les
autorités d'états de la guyane ne
veulent pas entendre qu'il y à d'autres
voies il manquait 300 professionnels de
santé dans les hôpitaux le corps il n'a
été que moins dire un révélateur ou un
explosif
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en place
depuis plus d'un an a été prorogée en
guyane jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour
faire face à la quatrième vague
épidémique un territoire dans lequel le
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 cents à
convaincre 32% de la population ont reçu
au moins une dose de sérum contre 75 en
métropole dans la tente d'une
concertation la préfecture a annoncé que
les stations-service rouvriront ce
mercredi mais la distribution d'essence
ne se fera qu'en quantité limitée avec
litres par véhicule de leur côté les
contestataires entendent reconduire
leurs actions jusqu'à l'ouverture de
discussions avec les autorités une
mobilisation qui n'est pas sans rappeler
le mouvement social qui avait marqué la
région il ya cinq ans les blocages des
axes routiers des commerces et des
stations essence avait duré plus d'un
mois
en pleine hommage un an après
l'assassinât de samuel petit un couple
d'enseignants étaient la cible de
menaces de mort à marseille à des
menaces reçues par courrier est
accompagné d'une photo de samuel patina
saison 34 ans on affirme être l'auteur
les autorités ont mis en place un
dispositif de sécurité pour les deux
professeurs le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin souligne je cite que les
autorités ne laisseront rien passer face
à ceux qui menacent nos enseignants fin
de citation et c a dans ce contexte que
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer a lancé ce mardi un plan de
formation des enseignants à la laïcité
il en a également profité pour rappeler
fermement aux professeurs leur tâche
transmettent les valeurs de la
république écouter
lorsqu'on devient professeur on devient
fonctionnaire lorsqu'on est
fonctionnaire de la république on
connaît les valeurs de la république et
on les transmet si quelqu'un a un
problème avec les valeurs de la
république ça peut être possible sur le
plan démocratique en tant que citoyen
français par contre ce n'est pas
possible en tant que fonctionnaire de la
république
si vous voulez devenir plombier et que
vous avez un problème avec des tuyaux
vous choisissez un autre métier il faut
en faire un autre si vous devenez
professeur vous transmettez les valeurs
de la république et si vous ne les
transmet tepa et si même vous militez
contre les valeurs de la république
éventuellement sortait de ce métier
parce que vous vous êtes trompés à un
moment donné ça n'a peut-être pas été
assez clair dans le passé ça va être
désormais très clair dans le présent et
dans le futur au travers de la formation
comme de la gestion de la carrière des
personnes est un rappel à l'ordre du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui mais sur le terrain des
enseignants refusent t'il vraiment
d'adhérer aux valeurs de la république
et de les transmettre à leurs élèves ou
la menace est elle aujourd'hui tels que
certains professeurs ont décidé de
baisser les bras notamment sur les
questions de laïcité vous êtes invité à
réagir sur le conte télégramme daté
france on vous pose cette question
transmettent les valeurs de la
république réalité ou utopie place à
notre débat tout de suite
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler gamal à bina
cofondateur du mouvement des droits
civiques bonsoir gamma d'amis d'un merci
d'être avec nous guillaume baissière
professeur d'histoire soutien des lic
zemmour merci d'être avec nous une
petite mise au point tout d'abord
aujourd'hui du ministre de l'éducation
nationale plutôt bienvenue ou plutôt
maladroit et âme à la binah je peux dire
ce que je pense d'eux des maladresses
qui sont succédé au gouvernement mais là
mais effectivement c'est assez maladroit
qui donne le sentiment qui est des
professeurs seraient pas enclins à
vouloir des valeurs de la république qui
sont je rappelle tout de même un petit
peu obligatoire aujourd'hui avec nos
droits civiques donc l'éducation civique
plus tôt donc je pense que c'est un
petit peu léger c'est des rappels qui
n'ont pas bien mort était alors vous
vous êtes justement le disait
professeurs pour l'utiliser puisque
soutien d'eric zemmour mais tout de même
professeur quand vous entendez le
ministre vous interpeller vous rappelle
qu'il faut rappeler ses valeurs de la
république comment vous réagissez alors
tout d'abord je suis professeur mais pas
politisée quand je suis professeur je ne
fais pas de politique a bien c'est bien
le préciser tout comme quand on est
journaliste on ne fait pas de politique
normalement donc vous ne faites pas de
politique à l'école c'est bien fait ça
j'ai même le contraire j'essaie de
pousser les élèves à réfléchir alors je
suis très surpris en effet de cette
déclaration de jean-michel blanquer qui
va selon m'a vraiment à rebours de ce
qui se passe dans le réel les
professeurs sont plutôt victimes on
vient de voir deux professeurs qui ont
été la cible justement de finalement de
menaces de mort donc je ne comprends pas
pourquoi jean michel blanquer a choisi
de victimiser les bourreaux je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas de de traiter les
victimes que sont les professeurs pour
l'instant
comme s'ils étaient suspects de ne pas
transmettre les valeurs de la république
ça veut dire quoi qui est un procès
d'intention à l'égard des professeurs
vont estimer de la part du ministre de
l'éducation là je réagis sans vraiment
l'avoir analysée mais je ne comprends
pas pourquoi il a fait cette sortie
aujourd'hui alors premier message
dannatt a levé sur les réseaux sociaux
télégramme il faut protéger nos
professeurs les vrais garants de la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
gavelle abina ce sont les vrais garants
de la transmission des valeurs
républicaines est ce qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de choses qui pèse sur les
épaules des des professeurs dans un
contexte parfois tendue est ce que c'est
vraiment leur rôle à eux et de manière
exclusive c'est intéressant que la
professeure sur le sol sur le plateau
aussi bien bien évidemment la question
et morgan parra mais non je pense
que on leur fait peser beaucoup trop de
choses sur les épaules pour deux raisons
la première parce que ce n'est pas leur
rôle clairement les valeurs qu'on dont
on parle de la république s'est pas
séparé l'école de les transmettre c'est
pas j'ai été choquée moi pour
l'éducation civique j'ai pas compris
parce que j'ai pas connu ça quand
j'étais plus jeune j'ai eu et j'ai
échappé à ce genre de plaisanterie on a
fait du droit mais très tard évidemment
mais en aucun cas de l'éducation civique
ça ne veut rien dire on veut transmettre
des valeurs qui sont des valeurs
partagées par tous deux fait puisqu'on
est citoyen de droits et de devoirs mais
ces valeurs là ça va peut-être davantage
besoin aujourd'hui les rappels peut-être
question de la laïcité est pas certain
que ça le problème c'est que les
questions de laïcité qui sont posées
sont des questions qui sont liées à
l'exclusion simplement quand on parle de
laïcité en règle générale on ne cible
pas les catholiques ils ont compris avec
la halle avec labatt et des quatre avec
les écoles privées sous contrat c'est
plus la question qui se pose au risque
de voir les gens qui sont ici une de
banlieue dont on imagine qu'il serait
musulmans pour la plupart d'entre eux
serait une sorte de cinquième colonne
qui voudraient imposer d'autres valeurs
qui serait l'alternative à l'appui que
ça ça n'a pas de sens dans la mesure où
si vous allez la rue petit par exemple
dans le 10ème arrondissement vous avez
des tonnes d'écoles juives qui ne pose
aucun problème ils ne sont pas
incompatibles et gratuit on respecte la
loi cela fait on ne va pas déborder sur
le cadre légal mais on est on impose
passer ces règles personnel à
l'extérieur on sait à poser soi-même
donc c'est vrai que ces questions de
mettre une charge ciel lourd sur les
professeurs pour leur demander d'en
signer valeur keynes truc qui s'enseigne
pas à l'école abrite et ailleurs ça
c'est pas compréhensible alors c'est
vrai que il ya un contexte particulier
on a parlé cet hommage à samuel pâtit 98
incidents recensés notamment cet homme
qui est toujours en garde à vue depuis
lundi pour avoir menacé de mort le
personnel d'un collège dans la drôme où
son fils avait écopé d'un avertissement
après avoir crié allahu akbhar lors d'un
hommage de 2 samuel bâtisse n'est
malheureusement pas un cas isolé il ya
aussi aujourd'hui dans l'actualité ce
couple menacé à marseille photo12 samuel
petit elle à l'appui on je le répète une
centaine d'incidents relevé qu'est ce
que ça dit guillaume baissière ça vous
évoque quoi un jeu tout d'abord je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec l'analyse de
monsieur abina au sujet du fait que les
professeurs on leur demande trop où
l'entente de l'éducation et l'éducation
c'est le rôle de la famille dont
peut-être qu'il a eu une faillite à sun
à ce niveau là est ce que m'évoque ces
symptômes donc ces voix-là 98 d'une
petite centaine de cas d'incident
relever concerne leurs seins c'est
exactement eh bien ça me pour moi ce
sont des symptômes que que la france
n'est pas apaisée et que souvent on peut
entendre dire que eric zemmour lui
essaye de mener une guerre ou de créer
une guerre mais finalement il ya déjà un
conflit il est là lui met des mots sur
les maux il constate ce conflit et il
explique il veut en chercher les causes
le diagnostic pour pour proposer une
solution alors qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas c'est tout à fait légitime d'en
débattre mais lui dit il y à un symptôme
est donc pour moi ces manifestations le
manifeste jenson
l'exil est rassurant tout gamin la mine
à votre avis là-dessus sentent une
centaine d'incidents cas isolé ou ouvrez
maux de la société comme un ensemble le
penser chez eric zemmour nord et les
maux de la société s'exprime par une
chose claire c'est un caractère le
caractère de l'exclusion des gens qui
vivent en banlieue en règle générale
alors il ya toujours des petits voyous
des peas abc les provocateurs cette
affaire du monde qui a prouvé qu'elle
professeur et qui crient allah ouakbar
on sent bien que c'est geronimo qui
parle ça ne veut rien dire félicité par
son père qui lui valent adultes aux
locateurs ses provocations bête parce
qu'ils n'ont pas mesuré la gravité de
l'assassinât de cet honneur faut
rappeler quand même une femme a été
décapitée ya encore quelques jours 77
ans avec ce professeur des écoles est la
même qui a fait ça est à même de
l'extrême droite bon apparemment matin
il a été premier mémoire et tout oublié
mais quoi qu'il en soit et c'est le même
constat que je fais la barbarie et la
barbarie alors maintenant on cherche à
sous jacent religieux qui aurait une
sorte de réflexion antérieures ou qui
sera organisée je tiens à dire une chose
ce soir parce que là où vous parlez
banque vous êtes très sympathique un
problème et mais vous avez rejoint un
homme qui n'est pas malheureusement et
qui a des gros problèmes d'analystes qui
n'a pas le courage de venir parler à des
gens dont il parle tout le temps je
parle des gens comme nous moi je suis
prêt à attendre sur n'importe quel débat
et à ce moment là on verra qui en plus
ne nous briseront auteurs le prêt de
monsieur zemmour c'est qu'il parle de
problématiques qui sont des cas isolés
des cas marginaux et qu'il met des
problématiques en avant qui reste des
problématiques marginal évidemment que
c'est choquant qu'un homme se fasse
décapité et ça on discute même pas là
dessus moi j'ai l'amour des livres dont
je n'accepte pas qu'on vienne avait
violenté l'homme qui est là pour donner
des connaissances en revanche lorsque la
france est en train de sombrer avec une
dette abyssale lorsqu'il ya des
problèmes par rapport aux convives qui
ont tués comme des centaines de milliers
de personnes dont des familles
endeuillées lorsqu'on à l'incapacité
chronique de sortir ce pays du marasme
dans lequel il s'est enfoncé avec la
désindustrialisation et il en parle moi
ce qu'il reproche à monsieur zemmour
c'est quoi c'est qui ne donne pas de
réponse sa réponse est systématique
c'est la problématique c'est les
banlieues la problématique c'est la
question avec eux sont familiales ce qui
est une c'est à la marge tout ça est
aujourd'hui s'il a le courage
d'affronter les gens dont il parle tout
le temps il ne fait pas mal moi je pense
qu'il est courageux j'espère pour lui si
la ce courage à ce moment là j'attends
quand il veut et on pourra débattre mais
on pourra débattre de vraies questions
qui n'abordent jamais parce qu'il est
pas en mesure de répondre aux questions
économiques il ne sait pas faire
c'est un homme qui veut briguer la
magistrature suprême et qui vous parle
d'incidents marginaux je disais
aujourd'hui les gels et je ne parlais
pas des banlieues j'ai jaune ils ont
peur par rapport à ce qu'ils dormaient
dans leur assiette donc c'est en ça que
je dis c'est 98 cas recensés qui arrive
évidemment reste des cas de soi de
provocation abc il faut les condamner je
vois des gens qui sont des totaux ratés
qui ont raté leur vie et qui n'ont rien
à perdre et quand on n'a rien à perdre
fait de graves fautes des bêtises ou des
meurtres en l'occurrence et c'est ça
qu'on doit poser comme question quel est
le vrai problème est ce que le problème
est lié à une sorte de nature c'est
inhérent la nature de ces gens ou est ce
que c'est un problème de fabrication de
monstres la fabrique de monstres en
france je vais annoncer juste un truc
très rapidement on n'y a pas de baboo
schiste en france et on espère qu'il n'y
aura pas de zemmouri ce temps
aujourd'hui on a des zones qui sont
exclus et ces gens explique ne rêve que
de vivre dans d'autres quartiers tous
autant qu'ils sont alors on va vous
laisser répondre on fait un petit détour
par ce message qui puise dans dans vos
propos la laïcité en tout cas selon
capter qui nous écrit est bafouée elle
qui protège nos valeurs républicaines et
notre devise de fraternité si je vous
comprends bien gamal amina il n'y a pas
de problème de roger de la laïcité
priori en tout cas pas de problème ancré
sur ce thème en france votre réponse aux
lions baissière là il y aura d accord
sur le constat parce que je pense que ce
ne sont pas des cas marginaux je vois
que c'est endémique avec les chiffres de
l'insécurité
mon expérience
alors mon expérience de professeur
on a considéré quand j'étais au lycée
professionnel les menaces de mort que
j'ai eue c'était alors évidemment oui
oui alors mais pour moi c'était
tellement ben voila c'était finalement
non ce n'était pas normal j'étais choqué
mais je n'avais pas de victimiser on n'a
pas fait de tribunes de choses comme ça
enfin parce que c'est pas la manière
dont je conçois la vie fait décapiter
entre temps alors peut être qu'on a
tendance à vouloir se protéger en
médiatisant peut-être en tout cas
ces crimes il y en avait
non c'était c'était avant c'était avant
donc bon voilà un jeune qui me menace
quel geste de l'égorgement et qui me dit
mort aux mécréants et un autre un moment
qu'ils vivent et voilà sur le coran g de
fumer dehors
avec d'autres expressions
voilà donc pour moi et alors je n'aime
pas trop qu'on parle de la vie
personnelle parce que finalement ainsi
quelqu'un
d'autre
[Musique]
c'est un mal qui existe vraiment comment
vous aime et lisez ce genre justement de
menaces une provocation comme le dit
games à la villa ou un mal effectivement
plus profonde de notre société on bafoue
justement la laïcité alors je crois que
c'est un mal plus profond de la société
mais pas parce que j'ai été concernés je
crois que c'est trop facile de ne
s'intéresser à des sujets sociétaux que
lorsqu'on lévis c'est pour ça qu'une
frange de la population française qui
dit y'a pas de soucis d'immigration tout
simplement parce qu'ils se payent la
sécurité
c'est à dire que quand on paye d'aider
des appartements à 12000 euros du mètre
carré l'antico avec voilà qui sont anti
donc le design est pas de souci a pas de
souci mais c'est facile c'est sûr quand
on est dans ces eaux là de dire y'a pas
de problème est de dire que l'écologie
ça et ils vivent pas dans les beaux
quartiers à l'économiste ah oui mais
justement le vote communiste qui était
plutôt populaire une époque est passé
alors j'ai pas dire l'extrême droite
mais passé au front national et c'est
pour ça que maintenant l'électorat de la
gauche finalement c'est de moins en
moins le peuple et qui a cette volonté
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'islam au
gauchisme qui est un mot bon un peu
fourre tout au théâtre voilà je
comprends que ça fasse ça se sent un peu
trop dossier médical c'est juste
ridicule mais je ne pense pas en
revanche c'est importer des électeurs ça
c'est déjà fait on a pu voir ça aux
états unis et c'est exactement la
stratégie de certains partis politiques
et d'une mentalité gauchistes
je réponds ça
fait la porte sa femme aux gauchistes de
ces concepts abscons qui veut rien dire
qui veut dire que des gens de gauche ou
d'extrême gauche avait été par la gauche
be extrême gauche serait plutôt
favorable est courant aux musulmans mais
c'est pas ce qui se passe l'extrême
gauche voit bien avec mélenchon il a dix
courtiers double à la fois il est
contrôle religieux de fait il il
suffisait qu'une fois et en même temps
de l'autre côté il a envie d'avoir un
vote qu'on va appeler communautaire pour
dire je suis pas le pire je vais vous
aider je vais calmer les choses on va
était l'islam au gauchisme c'est de dire
que des gens d'extrême gauche sera en
soutien à des islamistes ça qui est
grave c'est pour ça que je dise que ce
terme ne veut rien dire c'est un thème
qui est abscons et qui est surtout
disqualifiant en vérité les gens
d'extrême gauche ne sont pas du tout
très peu croyants et pas du tout
favorable des cours à comment courants
radicaux islamistes ou ce que
l'islamisme si on se situe sur
l'échiquier politique c'est plutôt à
droite c'est du conservatisme donc en
cela c'est cette idée d' islamo
gauchistes c'est façon disqualifiée hier
une autre thème qui est utilisée aussi
l'indigénisme alors cela c'est pour
disqualifier des gens qui sont de gauche
mais qui sont contre le néocolonialisme
ou le code de l'indigénat concours
produirait dans les banlieues c'est une
façon chaque fois de dire à des gens qui
sont racisées le terme est valable à
dessus ces records autour on voit matt
et on sait que j'appelle ici pour dire
vous n'avez pas voir la parole vous
devez pas parlé parce que vous aidera
nos d'hygiéniste donc le saas et les
méthodes souvent qui viennent d'extrême
droite pour disqualifier la personne qui
plus utiliser un terme qui n'est pas les
français se victimise le verbe victime
s'est pas victimiser texte parle
d'accord ça c'est un terme qu'on la
récupère et des états unis victimisation
ça n'existe pas en france donc quelqu'un
qui aurait une posture victimaire adia
cela d'abord on n'est pas des victimes
il ya une réalité sociale qui hisse en
france il ya une exclusion qui
manifestent il ya un mécanisme des
décideurs je parle pas de la population
française qui les parlent concernés les
décideurs qui font en sorte qu'on reste
en parler j'ai posé une question devait
très simple quand j'hésite à leur
légende dans l'ue et veulent partir de
mauvais quartier c'est normal comme tout
le monde sur la plage en on va quand
même un peu meilleure mais comment se
fait-il qu'ils ont ils ont été
concentrées là dedans monsieur zemmour
prétend qu'il y aurait une fabrication
une colonisation de musulmans je raconte
des choses et moore que si on avait le
pouvoir sur les commissions
d'attribution de hlm il ya longtemps
qu'on serait dans le xvième donc c'est
un mensonge malheureusement il manipule
beaucoup les chiffres contrôler quand il
parle il y avait 80 % de musulmans dans
les prisons il s'est ravisé pasquet les
enquêtes qui ont été menées c'est plus
de 25% j'allais dire à ce monsieur
zemmour qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est 75 %
d'européens délinquants donc ça je vous
dis le problème qui se pose c'est qu'il
a une analyse de choses qui est fausse
ils vous parlent de montrer qu'il a
connu il ya 40 ans c'est un canton
pratiquement dans une situation qui a
évolué et qui a gravement dégénéré c'est
ça qui se pose aujourd'hui s'cusez moi
premier regard non mais et le mot de la
fin des jeux
je comprends tout à fait mais si on
apporte les banlieues dans le 16e et
bien le 16e deviendra montreuil et vous
dites que l'islamo gauchisme et abscons
et je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
stupide de la part du gauchisme qui a
été très l'écart anti chrétiens et pour
mettre l'église à sa place pendant
longtemps de pactiser avec l'islamisme
qui finalement on les appelle les idiots
utiles alors tout le monde est idiot
utile
exactement mais il n'a pas tort tout le
temps et bien ce sont des idiots utiles
parce que quand ce sera trop tard et
bien finalement leur rêve d'élection ce
sera sur un chaos total
nous voulons éviter ça je sais vraiment
pas mérité la france c'est là que je
vais vous votre erreur c'est pour vous a
dit ça quand vous rejoignez un monsieur
zemmour c'est qu'il a été éduqué par un
alain soral le mythe de la guerre civile
qui est une obsession qui est une des
obsessions fosse se constitue par des
peurs qui sont immatérielles la guerre
civile si vous la regardez les
statistiques vous êtes protégé
l'agression par journée ça c'est réel
c'est la délinquance non c'est pas vrai
les records g l'époque c'était pire
d'accord n'ont pas pas autant apprécié
temps mais si vous êtes pro d'histoire
vous être avec les guerres civiles sont
l'aliment de l'extérieur il faut deux
factions relais avec deux idéologies
aujourd'hui n'y a pas de soutien ces
gens-là ans par les musulmans de
banlieue n'ont aucun soutien ni les pays
d'origine une personne il ya quelques il
ya quelques loups blancs et les calculs
fera ou lors il ya quelques loup
solitaire plutôt qu'ils vont commettre
des actions violentes dont ils savent
parfaitement qu'ils vont être abattus
derrière et le savent donc cédé
suicidaire 50 ans c'est violent est
gratuit mais ça ne mène nulle part il
n'y a pas vraiment de vraie idéologie ce
qui est intègre et qui est inquiétant
pour lui vient de sa vie
comme il ya quand même disons année le
wahhabisme j'ai un peu étudiée et c'est
intéressant donc pas d'idéologie c'est
en pot sur une feuille mais en tout cas
les élèves qui
qui crée enfin vous à la ouate bao qui
s'amusent à
gâcher la noblesse et la provocation oui
mais ce sont eux et pour eux ça rejoint
quand même une nébuleuse alors si vous
voulez pas pc à l'idéologie ça rejoint
un fantasme islamiste qui correspond
peut-être à une société à une frange de
la société ont paupérisation mais on n'a
pas ça dans le cantal ayé venise dans la
halle aux années c'est une autre époque
pas refaire l'histoire c'est un peu long
mais en substance
c'est un long débat mais ce que vous
appelez islamisme c'est un courant
idéologique qui vient d'arabie
effectivement et qu'il comptait à
l'ablation des d'accord le principe on
mélange islamisme d'arabie des frères
musulmans mélange tout comprend rien à
rien il ya un islamisme complètement
déstructuré qu'est le ça et le
wahhabisme comme la paix d'accord pour
la paix les djihadistes et un islamisme
structuré qui est frères musulmans qui
est plutôt légaliste et eux ils
mélangent les deux il veut me dire que
le coupeur la gorge ses frères musulmans
mais c'est pas vrai c'est très complexe
il faut en parler avec un peu plus de
d'apaisement et de temps avec mother la
prochaine fois merci en tout cas tous
les deux guillaume veyssière gamme
alabina d'avoir été avec nous on se
retrouve demain pour un nouveau numéro
en attendant l'actualité continue toute
la soirée sur arte france
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres et le silence qui parle
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'afrique connect chef de
l'état en afrique pour ce poste certains
semblent avoir signé un contrat à durée
indéterminée président à vie en perdre
la vie ou forcés de quitter le pouvoir à
la faveur d'un coup d'état a parmi les
records de longévité on peut citer -
marc kadhafi 40 ans à deux pouvoirs en
libye 33 ans pour félix houphouët boigny
en côte d'ivoire 37 ans de pouvoir
cumuler comme premier ministre